Whew, that feels good.
We solved everything.
>> Not everything.
So we handled the two
relatively easy cases,
though that second one I admit was
a little bit more of a workout.
The next one is going to
be conceptually trickier.
But the algebra's not
going to be much worse and
this is going to be in
the context of reward shaping.
So, have you heard this phrase
Reward Shaping, before?
It comes up often when
people are talking about,
wow, how did they train that
dolphin to jump through a hoop?
So it's tricky to imagine how you might
have gotten a dolphin to jump through
a flaming hoop, out of the water and
then splashing down on the other side.
Because it's not the kind of
thing if you were to train it.
Well you can't tell it what to do.
Because they tend not to
listen unless you go [NOISE].
And you can't reward it just for
having done the right thing.
Because if you've had this flaming hoop
up in the air and you just wait for
the dolphin to jump through it and
you give it a treat.
Plus one if it does it and
otherwise you don't give it a treat
it's never going to figure that out.
It's never going to inadvertently
hop through that hoop and say, hey,
do I get a reward?
So, how do you suppose they
actually train dolphins to do this?
>> I have no idea, but I'm going to
guess about how they do this.
Because I'm not as into
dolphins as you apparently are.
What I assume that they do is they have
to coax the dolphin to jump through
the hoop in the first place, by making
it worth his or her while to do.
So you kind of reward it maybe for
jumping first and
then getting near the hoop
without the fire, with the fire.
You just keep giving it kind of
rewards for getting close enough until
it rather than inadvertently
jumping through the hoop,
decides that that must be
the right thing to do now.
>> Yeah, I think that's
[LAUGH] some approximation
of what I imagine that they'd do.
My understanding is that they'll
start off with something like
you put the hoop in the water.
And you put a fish next to the hoop,
right?
So that the dolphin swims over and
eats the fish.
And then you start saying
to the dolphin, well,
you start changing when
you pay off the dolphin.
You don't give it fish for just touching
the hoop, or for being near the hoop.
You give it a fish for
actually touching it with its nose.
And then you lift it out of
the water a little bit, and
then it has to swim
faster to get up to it.
And then you lift it out of
the water a little more and
it has to jump all the way through.
And then,
yeah once it's all the way at the top
eventually you can light
on the fire I guess.
I actually don't think I ever seen
a dolphin jump through a flaming hoop.
So we might want to
extinguish some of that.
But that's not really the point.
The point is that it's this
series of mini rewards
along the route to the big payoff that
helps provide the right kind of hints.
>> That's cool.
>> I'm going to say life.
Like you don't have to
just say grad school.
Like most of the things
we do are like this.
We don't wait to
get the big reward after we've
inadvertently done the desired behavior.
We get hints along the way.
>> You've clearly never
met any of my students.
But okay.